what if oil dropped to 20 or even $10 a
barrel that's probably not gonna happen
but it could if oil companies run out of
places to store their oil here's how
storage problem number one we're still
pumping too much oil
even after prices crashed by more than
50 percent America's oil boom continues
to flood the market most of that oil is
transported to storage sites where it's
held in tanks until it's sold but
investors are betting that prices are
bound to go back up again and that's
creating storage problem number two
investors are hoarding oil if you think
the price of oil is going to be higher
in the future it pays to store now and
so later that's exactly what investors
are doing oil storage is at its highest
level ever and that leads us to problem
number three its maintenance season
every year refinery schedule repairs for
spring refineries are where crude oil is
turned into familiar products like
gasoline and jet fuel so when refineries
are offline the oil has no place to go
the tanks keep filling so what are the
chances the US will max out its storage
Bloomberg intelligence crunched the
numbers from the past ten years if 2015
follows a normal pattern of planned
maintenance the two biggest u.s. storage
hubs would use up no more than 86
percent of their capacity no problem but
if there's a major unplanned refinery
interruption storage would truly run out
that's a crisis if it happens prices
would drop rapidly possibly to $20 a
barrel or lower oil imports would
decline first followed by a slowdown in
US production it's not like the US would
suddenly stop pumping but oil below 20
bucks that's uncharted territory